>> HEY THERE, BOYS, WE KNOW THE
LAST COUPLE MONTHS HAVE BEEN
FRIGGIN' INSANE.
ALL THESE BIG, COOL, POWERFUL
GUYS ARE TURNING OUT TO BE --
WHAT'S THE WORD?
HABITUAL PREDATORS?
CAT'S OUT OF THE BAG.
WOMEN GET HARASSED ALL THE TIME.
>> IT'S LIKE, DANG, IS THIS THE
WORLD NOW?
BUT HERE'S A LITTLE SECRET THAT
EVERY GIRL KNOWS.
OH, THIS BENDS THE DAMN WORLD.
♪ IT'S FREAKY AND NARCY
AND FUN UNDER THE JET SET
BUT THIS IS OUR HOME NOW
WE'LL SHOW YOU AROUND ♪
♪ WELCOME TO HELL
NOW WE'RE ALL IN HERE
LOOK AROUND ISN'T IT NICE
IT'S A FULL NIGHTMARE ♪
♪ AIN'T IT SO COOL
PLAYING THIS GUESS WHO
YEAH IT'S A LOT
BUT IT'S WHAT WE GOT ♪
♪ WELCOME TO HELL
HEY ♪
♪♪♪
OH, AND THIS AIN'T A GIRL GROUP.
WE JUST TRAVEL IN A PACK FOR
SAFETY.
IT'S HOW I WALK HOME AT NIGHT.
DAD GAVE ME A PINK GUN.
SO THERE'S A LOT THERE.
MY LITTLE TRUTH,
IF SOMEONE IS FOLLOWING ME I PUT
MY ARM UP LIKE THIS, AND I GO
AWWW.
THEN HE'LL BE LIKE, SHE'S NOT
WORTH THE TROUBLE.
♪ WELCOME TO HELL
NOW YOU'RE IN OUR BOAT
LOOK AT THAT GUY ♪
♪ WHAT IS HE UP TO
IN THAT TRENCH COAT
IT'S LIKE A MAZE HERE
ALL FULL OF BONERS ♪
♪ HEY WHAT WAS THAT
JUST A CAT
WAIT WHO OWNS THE CAT
COULD BE A TRAP ♪
♪ WELCOME TO HELL
HEY ♪
♪♪♪
>> I GUESS IT BEGS THE QUESTION,
WHOA, WHY DIDN'T YOU SAY
SOMETHING BABY, GIRL?
>> WELL, THANKS DEVIL DADDY.
WE DEFINITELY DID, FOR HUNDREDS
OF YEARS.
>> OH, MAN.
>> BECAUSE NO ONE REALLY CARED.
>> BECAUSE IT KEPT HAPPENING
AGAIN.
>> WHAT?
>> AND AGAIN.
>> REALLY?
>> OH, COME ON.
>> HEY, JUST WANTED TO SAY, I
THINK WHAT YOU GUYS ARE DOING IS
REALLY COOL.
I GET IT.
BUT YOU DO KNOW THAT IT'S LIKE A
MILLION TIMES WORSE FOR A WOMAN
OF COLOR, RIGHT?
>> OH, GOD, YES.
>> THANK YOU FOR SAYING THAT.
>> YES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WELL, LET'S GET BACK INTO
THIS.
♪ NOW HOUSE OF CARDS
IS RUINED
AND THAT REALLY SUCKS ♪
♪ WELL HERE'S A LIST
OF STUFF
THAT'S RUINED FOR US ♪
♪ PARKING AND WALKING
AND UBER AND PONY TAIL
BATH ROBES AND NIGHT TIME ♪
♪ AND DRINKING IN
HOTELS AND MEN
>> NOTHING GOOD HAPPENS IN A
VAN.
WELCOME TO HELL ♪
♪ WELCOME TO HELL
THIS ISN'T NEW
NO NO NO NOT NEW ♪
♪ OUR SITUATION
HAS BEEN HERE
SINCE WE GOT BOOBS ♪
♪ I GOT SOME BOOBS
THAT'S WHY YOUR MAMA
IS ALWAYS SO TIRED ♪
♪ GRAB ALL YOUR FRIENDS
MACE IN HER HANDS
WELCOME TO HELL ♪
YEAH, IT AIN'T FAIR, BUT
♪ SO PULL UP A CHAIR
WELCOME TO HELL
HEY ♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]